When you work out your shit. Now I've seen
you at the comedy store, but only once.
Where, where do you work out your shit?
I like to go to random comedy clubs.
You know, I think I'd go to
New York first. Uh, New York
has always been, uh, a home,
um, when it comes to building, uh,
putting some structure within a set
that you're trying to figure out.
Once I got a skeleton of what I want
to do, I've just go to West Palm.
Uh, I love that comedy club, the
Improv down there, and I'll stay,
I'll stay for two weeks. Oh real. And
just go and run through some jokes.
I'll go to Utah.
I'll go to Denver.
Who Do like wiseguys. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I'll go to comedy clubs.
Just random comedy clubs that
you would expect to see me yet.
But I'll do a hell of a run.
And the goal is to get out of
there with just a foundation.
It's not to have a complete set.
I just want to get a foundation.
So when I'm done getting the foundation,
then I'll do a little comedy club run.
I'll do a full comedy club run where I
just put two or three months in and it's
come to club comedy club comedy club
and I'm doing seven shows a weekend and
people were shocked that
I'm there and that I'm doing
it, but you know, that's my,
that's my gym.
That's how I work.
And I ended up leaving that period of
time with a complete set after the first
three or four months that I
spent now after the comedy club,
three to four months don't that run.
Then I'll take it to like a small theater.
I'll see what my laugh to feels like in
the small theater and I'll do a little
run in small theaters.
And then when I finally feel like it's
at a point where I'm getting the laugh
consistently and the punch lines of
working and I flipped it back front,
what's forward?
Every direction and my story is a real
roller coaster and it has an ending where
I feel like we get off the roller coaster
and we're happy and you don't feel
like you were there for an hour.
Then when I go test it out in
that arena and if they arena,
if the last or sounds the
way it's supposed to, then
I'll say, okay, I'm ready.
If it doesn't,
then I'll go back to small theaters
and then I'll go to an arena again.
So not to that arena sounds
the way it's supposed to do.
I say I'm going on a tour,
so sometimes it takes me about a year,
a year and three months, a
year and four months. You know,
people don't understand how hard it is
to develop an hour of standup material.
You know? People act like you
just turn on a new hour. It's,
it's an hour to get to an hour.
You're going through four to five hours
of bullshit that you thought was funny.
Yeah. To come up to that
hour that you finally say,
this is going to be the
representation of me this year. Yeah.
It's a lot for me to do that, especially
at this level, you know? Well,
especially while you're always doing
movies and you're always busy with a bunch
of other stuff to stuff that you don't
love me. You don't take any breaks.
Why tour? I actually, you know, when
I'm touring, if there's a movie,
I make the movie schedule around
a tourist, so my shooting days,
we'll go Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday rep,
Thursday maybe ever show Thursday night,
and then I'm going Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, sometimes no
show Sunday, sometimes show Sunday,
depending on what the work schedule
and the workload for the following week
would look like. So I'm implementing
that in, so when I say I'm out, I'm out,
I'm gone.
Yeah.
So I've knocked that movie out in two
months and then when I'm not that tour
scheduled shifts. So the Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, dedicated to family,
dedicated to the office, everything.
Then those weekends or tour.
But the tour lasts for a year and a half.
I mean this year we did 157 shows
on my air responsible tour. Wow.
Hundred and 57 show before you decided
to put it on the Netflix special. Yeah,
we did the Netflix. The taping. I think
I did it three weeks before we were done,
so we probably had 143 shows.
Oh Wow.
Then I taped it and finished the tour.
Did you always have this kind
of structure? Like when did you,
how did you design this thought out
individually? Yeah. You seem like I am a,
I may well thought out
individually random. No,
everything is planned.
If you look at all my standup specials,
there's a two year gap in between them.
So the two year gap is because
at the end of that second year,
my new special should be coming out
when a new special should be coming out.
I'm now focusing on what the
next special is going to be.
So that first year is all development.
Like right now I'm off,
I'm not touring,
but now I'm mentally in the gym and
throwing all the old stuff that I talked
about away that's now thrown out.
Can't repeat it, can't say it.
Now it's talking about with the new
version of myself is going to be,
what do I want the conversation to be?
What's my thinking and just taking notes.
So eventually now I'm going to start just
popping up at random comedy clubs and
trying to figure out
what the next thing is.
So by mid mid 20 I'll probably
be doing comedy clubs.
By the end of 20,
I should have a full fledge concept.
Did that new hour.
And by the beginning of 21 I should
be ready to go out with my new hour.
End of 21 film.
I knew our mid 20 to
that hour would come out.
That seems like a schedule a
lot of people are doing now.
The two years scheduled. It's a
perfect get. Yeah. That's how I do.
I know Louis Ck did a year every
year in George Carlin did every year.
But I think even he said that really
wasn't the right way. That's tough.
A year's tough. Yeah. I mean
that's a, that's a shouts
out to those that can do it.
I think that's amazing.
Um,
I think just for everything that I have
going on and all of the different things
that my hands are in within the brand,
the business,
I need to make sure that I'm giving
100% to those things so they have the
highest opportunity to be successful.
If I'm trying to cheat it,
then it's going to show you it's not going
to come out to the best of my ability
and will then stand up. You gotta you
gotta fucking magnifying glass on you.
You know, you're always being judged
off of what you did at one point,
just like a musician,
you're always off of the album that
everybody thought was whatever.
So the biggest thing for an entertainer,
artists, whatever your craft is,
his creation,
how you recreating yourself,
how are you constantly
showing that you're growing.